hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the impossible quiz now
someone told me that I needed to play
this because they thought that I was
stupid and I would fail so let's prove
them wrong Oh
slap me do presents presents the
impossible quiz I don't even need
instructions for this I'm just gonna go
on my way okay how many holes in a polo
what what does that even mean
what kind of question is that there's
two circles in that letter name Oh God
what's a bolo the shirt you talk of this
shirt
one for the head two for the buttons
three in a matchbox that one okay
Sidorov ik backwards Oh answer this
question backwards okay okay click no I
didn't even mean to do that okay put the
mouse on here
oh go around it I got it go got it
square root of onion what what what do
you mean the root of onion is a root so
the square root of it would be what are
shallots
the answer is really big
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
oh you dick
all right there's four holes no but a
tin can
okay click answer now it's here go all
the way over there
they're shallows okay the answer is
really big but as far as a polo remember
nobody can oh oh
but it's pointing to no it's ah choose
the food well this all depends on what
we eat Oh what am i doing
why am I doing this oh that one turns
into butter was that right
was I right on that cuz it turned yellow
into butter boys everything
[Music]
that is what oh I can skip it what
follows December 2nd abit what what
sounded the belt of make poop to tank
rune blip blop bloop Bango Langille roof
nothing for 120,000 echo do la loo
icecap bobbidi boo boo boo makes a ding
sound that's the ding sound that's been
ding in the whole time it's been making
a ding sound they let the bell when I do
the right answer
not a whoop
dang make it lighter towards the hole I
don't know what you're doing I don't
know if you mean to me to take it
literally or if you mean figuratively or
if you just douche I don't like you
Mattie whinny horse what what no what
are you doing no neigh Winnie
[Music]
abcdefg unless you mean me to take that
literally the alphabet t th e al pH I
[Music]
don't gotcha
I do not stop hammer time color in
correct order what you don't know what
that is
what is that ha lure in the correct
order what are you British I'm gonna
skip this one because it seems like a
bit of a douche
Deal or No Deal what sealer no seal does
that mean what do you mean deal or no
deal seal or no seal do a no deal deal
I faked every wrong seal why is it feel
watch what okay
the choice is yours ah
[Music]
Degas yep okay oh I literally skip Oh
Save Changes done titled yes maybe I
don't know I don't know what you want
for me anymore I'm questioning my entire
life now okay quick clip Oh
click the V in the lives okay where do
you kill a werewolf how do I wear how do
you kill a where where do you kill a
howl wolf that's whatever L really wants
to know what is a kill it bang
this is Cillit bang you talking about
[Music]
[Music]
okay which of these place names doesn't
exist
what do you mean place names well I
would love to go to brown Willy or
blubber houses or RZ I hope you've been
paying attention to the question numbers
what is Bethel easy I thought I was okay
I'm going to 28 hey what is that that is
a fairy cake Oh ballet bun abundance
cruel that is pretty cruel but I don't
if I if I was looking at that it's doing
ballet but it's a cupcake I don't know
what you want from me game Oh abundance
abundance Oh what flavor is cardboard I
don't know why would I know that it
depends on what you put in between the
two pieces of cardboard when you your
cardboard sandwich pork scratchings what
flavor is cardboard
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
one of the main ingredients of confu I
would believe cricket crap roundabout
right rocks and sausages that's in my
shampoo baby Chaman human faces cats and
well well I don't know what whelks are
but that sounds about right
rocks and sausages so how many letters
in this hand elephants don't like mice
oh the computer mouse squeak squeak
squeak pop I'll see what works quick
relevant how do I get I get it I get it
they don't like a computer mouse but
where's dub ya Wolfen I don't Xena I get
it but I don't see anything
oh-oh-oh
it's game over can I do that please Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what is Mary Rose sat on up in no I
don't know what you want from me space
serious business Linda Q lie down down
right here right now well it's not that
because he's facing left
he is cylindrical but he's not exactly
going on an adventure only I had a
bridge
[Music]
what's left I don't get it I don't get
it I don't get it Bridge B or idge i
right-clicked I don't know if that
showed up but I right-click wait what
what am I doing here what what do I do
[Music]
okay I don't get you I don't get you
what do you want
[Music]
you want me to click that okay good I
don't know what you want from me but
right before I died something popped up
at the bottom
[Music]
[Music]
so there's five times ten there's 50 42
so it's the 42nd 42 there we go
rigid makes everyone I don't know I
don't know I don't know who the hell is
Bridget
[Music]
I was puzzled nice puzzle nice puzzle
click the click the click click
[Music]
quick
[Music]
what I can't oh oh oh no oh no oh no
this is that weird text that you get
when you have a font error oh no oh no
[Music]
okay
I don't know the answer I don't think I
ever will I don't understand this was
that guy's poking him in the eye
oh are you sniffing out Sonic's eye or
nose I don't know what that is what is
that I don't know what it is so you're
looking at Sonic you're looking at hand
do i special oh my heavy you killed
sonikku you best dude ever don't know
what you want from me but I am trying my
best to understand you there's nothing
else weakly oh my ft you've killed sada
Cupid what is that what is it I don't
want it oh no my mouse go Oh No snake
snake which is correct spelling slap me
do oh this is the maker of the game
whose two-piece slap me blue red blue
yellow
what oh no oh please be the last
question I'm begging you I need to do
stuff I need to go live my life red blue
red blue yellow blue red blue yellow
blue red blue yellow okay okay
[Music]
[Music]
one away okay all right
[Music]
how many questions are there I can't I
can't I can't I need to live my life I
need to go I've got things that does me
doing I can't how close was I to the end
guys tell me in the comments below how
close I was to the end of this I've lost
all hope for all of humanity I will not
play another game like this for like two
or three days so anyway I hope you guys
enjoyed my misery thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos that I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]